all right well i can't believe i'm about
to tell this story
here we go oh god i don't even remember
how old i was this is [ __ ] amazing it
was it was i remember i don't remember
exactly how old it was but it was around
you know that age
as a teenager when you first discover
porn right yeah like you know anywhere
between like
i don't know 13 to 15 something like
that maybe even earlier for some people
i don't know
but uh i remember what it was too i
think it was legitimately the first time
i watched like a hentai on my computer
right
and you went straight to hentai this was
like
this is like not long after i discovered
porn
he quickly got down that rabbit hole
yeah i know like that that first time i
hid
but the first time with hentai was a
different story and i was in my room and
like
my room has like a had a lock on it
right so i thought
i'd lock the door oh oh no i thought
and i i remember it i remember what
which chant i was it was a kanojo
college of canada
classic classic right classic yeah yeah
yeah all right it's like next to libel
black
yeah yeah yeah and uh and yeah so i was
like
oh something has arose
in me
right so i was like let's give it a go
and so i did it and then uh i hear like
a a clack
of yeah the door opening and i'd look
around and it's my dad
standing there he's pretty he's pretty
proud of you though no no oh he looked
at me
and he looked at what was on my screen
and he looked at me again and he just
said
really mate
your dad seems like the most australian
man alive he just
i remember exactly what he said he's
like really mate couldn't have been
regular porn
he's like i wouldn't have i wouldn't
even be disappointed with you it was
just regular porn
and i was like i mean i've i've been
past that point i was kind of
experimenting he's like
all right whatever like i don't know
what i don't know why i have already
gotten bored of regular porn i i've i'm
seeking new
adventures i could i could legitimately
see the very moment where
the disappointment came you know what i
mean it's like it's like it's like a
certain look in my dad's eyes where it
kind of went from like whoa what are you
doing too oh
oh no he's into that he's into that [ __ ]
huh
oh yes father i am into that [ __ ] are
you winning son no no
that wasn't the day i took a nail that
was the day now he wastes his days
[ __ ]
and now i talk about it for a job so
yeah i hope you're proud of me dad
that felt so desperate please love me
please i'm winning now oh my god
i'm finally winning dad it's just that
that moment is carved into you and
you're you're like you're like the son
who just looks for your dad's approval
yeah i don't have a i don't have a lot
of like distinct memories during my
childhood but that was
definitely one that will like forever
stick with me like
it's kind of just implanted itself into
the back of my brain
yeah now i don't know i've i've never
been caught jacking off at all because
to me it's like
if if if i do this a checklist happens
you know like 100 for me yeah
yeah it's it's it's it's the same way my
sneak unfortunately
it's the same when you know you leave
the house and you have your
okay pat keys wallet phone same thing
same thing when when you do
the same thing same thing you know
you do you do the deed and you're just
like okay door locked headphones on or
whatever
make sure nobody's in the house or
nobody can hear and then you start see
with the lock on my door i got a little
too overconfident
so i'm like yeah this is this is this
foolproof isn't it and then i just i
guess i just forgot you know what it
felt like it felt like you know when
you're playing pokemon and you like
go into a cave and you put rappel on and
it runs out just before you're about to
leave the game
and you get into an encounter that's
what it felt like i was like [ __ ] i was
that close
yeah but i don't know like i've like i
i thought getting walked in on right
yeah is like a common thing because you
see it so much on the internet right
it's like i got walked in like what do i
do
like you know that kind of stuff so have
you ever walked in on anyone or been
walked in on
oh my god maybe i have i don't know i
feel like these are like buried memories
yeah like there's probably a good chance
i've probably walked in on something
like i don't know you've been to parties
and seen [ __ ] but like people just don't
care
they're just like i mean in like a
private time you know yeah no i don't
think i have actually
no yeah i i think i've never walked in
on someone but the closest i've come
is it was in university and i was uh
visiting a mate
and it was like a group house so uh like
two or three my mates are there and we
were getting ready for
the night out so i was just like saying
hello to everyone and then
um i knock on this i knock on one of my
mate's door
and i you know that panic scramble that
you can hear so his door was locked
right
but i i knock on the door and all i
heard was
[Music]
that's probably what i was doing
honestly that's all i heard
right and then he opens the door and the
laptop which is opposites like where the
door
is is conveniently closed so i'm just
like
what were you just doing and it was like
nothing i was just uh just working on my
presentation you know
yeah yeah i bet you i mean you were but
uh i've never actually walked in on
anyone but i feel like
it's more common in america because in
university there if you share a room
that's this is why i can't imagine
that's weird to me this is why i can't
imagine having a roommate
right because how do you how did you
schedule that did you
anyone in america can you ask me do you
do you actually have to schedule
your sessions because like do you have
to be like where are you going
yeah how long will you be at is this
just an urban life coming back this is
like an urban legend where do
you tell each other where do you like
did you like have like a calendar
where you schedule okay guys okay i'm
circling in boys
this time it's my time there's gonna be
a sock in the door that's how you know
and if the sock is on the door then it
is like
code red don't come in never disturb me
during my that time